Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche !
Hmmm !
C'est bon !
Salut les Épicurieux.
C'est un reblochon.
Drôle de nom pour un fromage !
Ce n'est pas celui d'un lieu-dit
ni celui d'un personnage.
Il n'estpas non plus lié à sa forme.
Alors d'où sort-il ?
Ce mot vient du patois savoyard :
« blocher »
qui signifie
« traire ».
Le préfixe « re »
indique la répétition de l'action.
La décomposition de ce mot coïncide avec une histoire
qui se transmet depuis des générations en Savoie.
Dès le XIIIème siècle,
les propriétaires des alpages,
en général des nobles ou des moines,
percevaient un impôt auprèsdes fermiers
qui y faisaient paître leurs troupeaux de vaches.
Ils étaient réglés
en nature,
en beurre,
en lait ou en fromage.
L'impôt était calculé sur la quantité de lait
produite chaque jour parle troupeau.
Cette quantité de lait
était vérifiée une fois par an par un contrôleur.
Ce jour-là,
les paysans réalisaient une traite incomplète.
La quantité de lait pesé
s'en trouvait donc diminuéepar rapport à la normale
et l'impôt aussi !
Aussitôt le contrôleur parti,
les fermiers retournaient finir la traite.
Ils allaient
« RE blocher ».
Le lait de cette deuxième traite,
même s'il n'était pastrès abondant,
était plus gras et donc idéal pour faire un fromage :
un RE blochon.
Et moi jevais RE goûter.
Au RE voir !
Hmmm, c'est bon !
C'est RE bon !